okay thank you very much
welcome everybody to this morning's
meeting first of all i'll have some
some uh housekeeping to rule read out if
i may
um members and visitors some
housekeeping before we start the main
business for today please turn off your
mobile phones or switch them to silent
i'll do the same um please set your
microphones to mute during the meeting
this is to ensure
that we don't get any feedback that will
affect our ability to hear proceedings
when you wish to speak please click on
the raise hand icon found by clicking on
participants
and clicking on the blue raised hand
icon at the bottom of the right screen
your raised hand icon will only be
lowered when i have invited you to speak
and you have spoken please unmute your
microphone when i invite you to speak
and mute it again when you have finished
speaking
please note that this meeting will be
live streamed to the council's youtube
channel today
please be mindful that therefore the
members of the public following the
meeting
via the live stream we'll be able to see
each of us on screen individually
please announce yourself by name when
speaking and if you want to refer to
anything in the office of the report
you can please first clearly state the
relevant page number
and paragraph number
um so there we go really so um
have we started live streaming yet yes
we're ready to start chairman
okay thank you very much for that it's
welcome to rocha district council's
remote meeting of the licensing and
appeals subcommittee and welcome to
anyone watching this via live stream
i now have some briefing notes good
morning my name is councillor
williams i am the chairman of the
licensing and appeals subcommittee
the other members uh i will ask them now
to
introduce themselves um so we have
uh lisa newport if you'd like to
introduce yourself please hi
councillor lisa newport
thank you and councillor jim gooding
i'm councillor jim gooding for south
ward
okay thank you very much and also um the
committee's legal advisor is mr chris
ewing if you would like to introduce
yourself please please
thank you chair yes uh chris erin says
to her rocha district council
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
the purpose of the hearing today is to
consider an application for the
variation of an existing premises
license
made by find build homes limited
relating to the premises
known as the the wacker 23 high street
great wakering
please could the council's license
introduce themselves
hello i'm carys brooke i'm the licensing
officer for rocha district council
thank you do you have any any witnesses
you wish to call
no no thank you um please could the
applicant
um or their representative introduce
themselves
yeah hi um so i'm tyler and this is jody
we're the two owners
of the wacker and finefield homes okay
thank you do you have any witnesses that
you wish to call
no thank you very much
um please got the interested parties or
their representatives
i've done that one
sorry please for the interested parties
or the representatives introduce
themselves
so you're a mute
still on mute if that's tracy strike
are you having trouble there sorry is
that better let's feel we can hear you
now
sorry about that we're just not very um
computer literate
that's okay um so sorry i'm tracy strike
and dave west i'm david westgar
so we we lived next door to the wacker
at number 17 high street
okay thank you and do you have any
witnesses that you'd like to call
no we don't know thank you have all the
parties receive the agenda and reports
for today's hearing
yes we have thank you
the committee will follow the procedure
set out the procedural note on
item three of the agenda please can all
parties be reminded that each have 15
minutes to present their case and will
be given two minutes at the end of the
hearing to make a closing statement
these time limits may only be extended
with the commission of the subcommittee
please could miss brook summarize the
application
thank you okay so this report introduces
an application for the variation of an
existing premises license
the application was submitted to the
licensing authority by the premises
license holders
fine build homes ltd and relates to the
premises known as the waka
23 high street great rayquin
the application for the following
licensable
activities are to include the use of the
outbuilding between 12 and 11 in the
beer garden for the existing premises to
be used for the supply and retail supply
of alcohol and
live music at the weekends the
application is also
is to also remove condition h which
states
that the entertainment to be provided
inside
only the application has been assessed
by essex police
and they have confirmed that they have
no representations
the application has been assessed by the
council's environmental health service
and they have agreed conditions with the
applicant for the committee to consider
should the application to vary the
license be granted
um all of these are included in appendix
c
there have been uh one representation
received from a local resident within
the consultation period
the representation raised concerns in
relation to the following licensing
objectives
prevention of crime and disorder
prevention of public
nuisance appendix d consists of a copy
of this valid representation
it is proposed that the committee
resolves the application with one of the
following
options to grant the application to vary
the existing license subject to such
conditions as
are consistent with the operating
schedule modified to such extent as
members consider necessary
or for the promotion for the promotion
of the licensing objectives
and any mandatory condition that must be
included or
to reject the application or subject to
paragraphs
11 to 13 of the licensing act 2003
hearings regulation 2005
to adjourn the hearing to a specified
date or arrange for a hearing to be held
on specified additional dates where
members consider this to be necessary
for their consideration or any
representation
representations on notice made by a
party
that's it is it thank you thank you does
anybody have any questions
for mr clarification needed
okay if the any other parties have any
questions for clarification
at all
no thank you
please could the applicant present their
submissions thank you
all right okay um so i suppose
we wanted to start by just giving a bit
of history of the pub
and what we've done with it and what we
intend to do with it
so we bought the pub in 2019
when it was a boarded up hub it been
failing for a number of years before
that
with several different landlords trying
to do stuff to the pub to make it work
none of which worked and it finally got
boarded up and sold to us
um at the time we had the opposite the
opportunity of developing the pub
and bill to turn it into flats or
housing or
some type of residential development but
was encouraged by the council to try to
keep the pub as it was
because it was deemed an asset to the
village um
so we decided to do that and we've
invested all our money into it we've
both remortgaged our
our own homes to pay for the refurb of
the pub and bring it up to where it is
today and we believe it's now
a big asset to the village um i think
most people in the village will agree
with that um
we're very responsible owners we we've
obviously gone through covid we've had
quite a difficult time
um we were actually mentioned by the
rockford council on their website for
how well we've done it as an example to
all the other pubs
as to our covered guidelines and how
well we've done
um we've kind of tried to turn the pub
into more of a food
place with more families and
we feel we're kind of doing that quite
successfully at the moment but it's got
to be financially viable so we've got to
keep improving the pub to make it work
and we've got a copy of the letter that
obviously tracy sent in and we'd just
like to address each point
as we go if we could quite briefly um
so i think the first point she brought
up or they brought up was the fact that
their properties are listed building
i don't think that has much bearing on
us because obviously we're not a listed
building
um our pub has been here before they
moved into the house and always has been
a pub
and hopefully always will be a pub so we
don't really see much
relevance to their building being listed
um
point two is the loss of enjoyment of
their outside space
and obviously again going through covid
we had to utilize our outside area
that was the only place we could have
people so naturally it was going to be
busier outside and we had to put extra
tables in
and the pub was empty the garden wasn't
that's so that's always going to happen
we we continue to close on a monday and
tuesday
um all other pubs in the village are
open seven days a week but we close
mondays and tuesdays
we feel that that gives our neighbors a
couple of days where the pub isn't open
it also gives our staff a couple of days
where we're not open
and it just gives everyone a bit of a
break really from the pub
um closing times our license allows us
to be open till one o'clock at the
weekend
and eleven o'clock eleven o'clock every
other day
we've taken the decision to close
earlier than that
because again as i said we're trying to
be more of a restaurant family place not
a late night drinking venue
so the weekends we close at 11 o'clock
on a sunday we close at nine o'clock and
during the week we close at 10 o'clock
latest
um the play area that we've
we've got at the back to be honest the
pub has always had a play area in the
garden
in actual fact the play area used to
take up probably about 60 percent of the
garden
whereas now our much smaller play area
probably only takes off about 10
of the garden so it's quite a lot
smaller um
we did when we bought the pub again
we feel we're quite responsible we put
up new fencing which is actually
acoustic fencing
it's probably about three times the
price of normal fencing but it does
help slightly with the acoustics for all
our neighbors
um i feel that kind of goes above what
most people would try to do
um i know the neighbors tracing david
actually removed a lot of the foliage
after we put the fence up which probably
didn't help because that was a natural
barrier before but that's now gone some
of that
um the outside bar that we've put up
actually moves tables away from their
fences
where we used to have two tables up
against the fence it's now pushed
the tables probably about seven or eight
meters away from the fence
and the bar itself has actually been
built with acoustic paneling
and sound proofing so it should help
um point number three they've said about
having piping music playing
it i mean i've got a lot to say on that
we simply don't
um we've got small speakers outside that
play incidental background music
again we're more of a restaurant place
we're not a nightclub we try to keep the
music as background music only
and number four um again we're not
i think it refers to the listed building
the fact that there's strict walls on
listed buildings
i accept that but that's obviously for
their own house not for us
there are improvements you can do to
enlisted building without the need for
planning such as secondary glazing or
soundproofing but that's something
obviously they need to consider
it's not something we need to consider
0.5 they've put lack of control which
we find quite hard to take to be fair
because we
have actually got security in place now
supplied by standby security um
the reason we got the security was for
code they do covered policing within the
building
they maintain volumes and keep if
anyone's noisy they will speak to them
they control numbers and obviously the
idea is they knit any
trouble before it actually becomes
trouble
we've had one incident you know i think
it was either the first week or the
second week we opened from
since covid back on the 12th of april it
was actually off of the premises however
we know that it was two people that had
been drinking
in the pub so we still know it's partly
our responsibility
um it's an isolated incident two
individuals
and we actually took one of the
individuals in looked after them and
called the emergency services ourselves
and everything was fine
since then the following weekend we had
our two doormen in place
and since then we've had absolutely no
problems at all and the doormen are very
good they're not
hard aggressive guys they actually get
on with everyone quite well
and since then since then that we
haven't had any problems at all and we
can't see why we ever would have now
we're the only pub that has got security
um
you know you can ask why we've got it
but we just feel that it it just
controls everything
and keeps it well organized i think on
that part as well with the security we
want to make sure that our
our pub um distracts
uh the sort of troublemakers or that
type of people we want nicer people in
the pub
and as we say we want it to be more of a
family orientated
place and so i think that's it's it's
not because we've had trouble
it's more to prevent prevent the trouble
and to
create a nicer environment and that's
what it is really and then point number
six
was i think it's condition eight about
live music outside
um we don't intend to have live music
outside every weekend
our live music is only ever a good a guy
on a guitar basically playing acoustic
background music
i think we all know in england the times
that this can happen
is quite rare um we've had one incident
where we
it was a really nice sunday for example
and the guitarist had to actually play
inside the pub to an empty pub when
everyone was sat in the garden
it just seems a shame that on them rare
occasions that we can't have a guy
playing his guitar
to you know a garden of people having
their roast dinners for example
it's not something that we're going to
have live bands rock and roll bands
playing music at the weekends it's
literally
a background acoustic guitarist playing
so we don't feel
that that you know i think that that
condition just shouldn't be on there
because it's not something we're going
to push
all the other pubs in the village seem
to be able to have live music outside
and we're the only ones that can't
it's um yeah it just seems a bit unfair
and then we've got i mean it's just a
bit of a close in summary i suppose
the pub is now busier than it ever has
been
um we do understand that and we see that
their point
obviously as a pub we need it has to be
busy for it to be financially viable
um if it isn't busy to be fair it's
worth more money as a development
we're doing everything we can to keep it
and get it going but we you know we
can't have our hands tied behind our
back really
the addition of the bar outside is not
going to bring any more noise
it's not there to encourage more people
although it may do but obviously
in all fairness that's you know that's a
good thing for us
um the idea of the bar is to alleviate
the pressure on the inside bar
and have people outside as opposed to
inside
um for example i think last week we had
a funeral here
it was very busy and we had we had it
about five deep at the bar
and it was just too busy we wasn't
comfortable with it although we
understand the covered restrictions have
been lifted
we're quite keen to keep a lot of our
things in place obviously because
because of the isolation rules and we've
had staff that got covered
so we want to try and keep limit that as
much as possible
so with the addition of the outside bar
it obviously means that we can keep a
lot of people outside
so fresh air and all that sort of thing
and it stops all the queuing inside it
but it also makes because it's more of a
restaurant
part it also makes it nice for the
customers that are in here
that they've not got loads of people
coming in here and queueing up at the
bar
so there's quite a few reasons for doing
it is it yeah
it's not just it's not just to bring in
people it's the same amount of p i mean
at the end of the day we've got a
capacity
that we have to stick to um the bar
simply means that people can go to the
outside bar to get a drink rather than
walk through the restaurant and get one
inside
which we think spreads the numbers out
and yeah obviously gives us more space
we have obviously spoke to licensing and
environmental health on this who have
come down
on a number of occasions um we feel
we've got a very good relationship with
them
and we've made some compromises already
that both licensing and environmental
health think of very fair compromises
and are happy with it and have agreed it
with us
um yeah other than the one complaint
that we've obviously had
and we've had no other complaints and i
know environmental health have said that
it's very
rare for a pub of our science to not
have any complaints in the
the nearly two years that we've been
open i know obviously covet we've been
shut but
we haven't had any complaints from any
neighbours other than this one incident
now
um again the pubs got to be financially
viable
and we're just trying to do everything
we can
we like to think i mean i know dave and
tracy have got our personal mobile
numbers
they know that if they need us they can
call us we've got a good relationship
with the other neighbours
um all of which frequent the pub and do
use the pub when they look when they
want to
um it's very really isn't it
yeah i think that's it i mean i know
dave obviously dave's a
a regular at our pub comes in every
thursday so i know
he enjoys the pub and haven't seen tracy
for a little while but
yeah we also you know we want to keep a
good relationship with all the
neighbours so hopefully um
it's something we can continue really
that's that's really all we want to do
okay thank you thank you very much for
that um
no other point you want to make at the
moment you will have an opportunity at
the end to sum up
yeah now i think that's that's fine for
now thanks okay thank you
um at this time we can now ask the
members of the subcommittee to uh
question you for
some clarification first of all um
one thing i'd like to ask if i made is
the uh piped music
are you anticipating having piped music
outside
no no so i think
also on our when we spoke to
environmental health i think they have
actually limited
it so that if we want live like bands
basically four or five piece bands
i think we're in we're only allowed one
is it one or two a year i think
um which is something they said they
would like so that we can't have
loud music every weekend and we had no
qualms with that whatsoever because it's
not our intention at all
okay it's basically so that if we want
we want to have like a couple of one-off
events
during the year we can just we can have
a live band outside but obviously we'd
give our neighbors notice of that as
well
so but that is definitely not the
intention okay
um the other thing when was the last
time have you ever had police called to
an incident
your premises yes we we called them on
the incident i referred to earlier which
happened in the first
week or two when we opened in on the
12th of april this year
um we called the police ourselves okay i
understand that you've been using
temporary event notices up until now is
that correct yeah
yeah we we have for the the tiki bar
outside but obviously because of the
rain as well we haven't been able to use
it a lot of the time so
it's not i think i think we've got to be
realistic here the bar is only ever
going to be used when it's nice weather
um this is going to be quite limited
it's not something that's going to be
open
you know every day we're open it's only
ever going to be open
of a weekend if it's nice weather and
we've agreed to shut it at half past 10
anyway
and we've got obviously the security
that are going to maintain the volumes
out there whilst it is open
okay all right well thank you for that
so i'm going to ask my fellow
uh councillors to offer any questions
council newport yeah you have your hand
up thank you
you're a mute counselor in newport sorry
i can't find the blue up hand eye
just a quick question you say you close
on
um mondays and tuesdays
is that uh a continual thing that's
that's just something that always
happens
it yes we've got no intention at the
moment of changing that
okay and also just a quick one if i may
about the security staff
um what hours and days have do they work
yeah so they work friday and saturdays
yeah
from about half five six o'clock till
close which is well that they leave at
half eleven
obviously the pub shuts at eleven so
it's very rare that anyone's in here
ten past eleven it's normally empty and
does that extend to bank holidays
well with the bank holidays so far have
been monday's where we're shut
so but going forward say christmas eve
new year's eve um good fridays
yeah i mean obviously the idea will be
they the security will be here
until the bar is shut down the tills
will shut down so they will be
here at any busy period like during the
football for example
i think there's a couple of um sunday
games and tuesday games we oh there's a
wednesday game
we will always have the security there
when we know it's going to be a busy day
wednesday and thursdays clearly are
quite quiet
as is a sunday so we would only the idea
is to have them here when
it's going to be busy and that will be
the same going forward over christmas
and et cetera
so if i made the bank holidays that
don't fall on a monday
you're quite happy to have the security
staff there
yeah yeah okay thank you is that all
comes from newport yep
thank you thank you um if if the um
having security staff would be made a
condition of this license
you would be happy with that uh no no
not really i don't
i feel it's something that we've gone
above what most people would probably do
but i don't think
it should be put compulsory on us i mean
a lot of the reason as well why we've
got securities because
um we've got a lot of female staff here
and it feels a lot more comfortable for
us as well to have
some of them some of the guys here
sometimes as well but i certainly don't
think we're not
we're no nightclub we're we're a
restaurant and i must admit a lot of our
customers do find it a bit odd that
we've
got dorman in um but definitely
it's it's not something we need it's not
something it's not like we're some sort
of club
it's something we've chosen to give us
peace of mind we know if we're at home
we know that the
there's going to be no trouble the place
is you know staffed it's got security
there
it means we can go home and not worry
about the place yeah but it's not
something we'd want to have compulsory i
think that's something that we've gone
above others to do it would be it would
yeah it'd be very strange to have that
as compulsory for a
village okay all right thank you very
much council goody
um you have your hand up if you'd like
to ask any questions thank you
yeah i apologize if i missed this but
how long have you
uh had stanbridge security being
employed by you
i'm not sure on the exact date but it i
believe it would have been the end of
april
this year yes right okay thanks thanks
that was all cheers anything else comes
to building
no that's it thanks right thank you very
much um
i'm now going to ask um the the in
interested parties to provide their
submissions if you can please
sorry chad did you want to just check if
any of the other parties had any
questions oh yeah i do apologize
have any questions for the applicants
so no i presume all right thank you for
that chris
right if i could if we could go back to
the interested parties please
you're on mute again tracy
still on mute
i'm sorry you're so mute we can't hear
you
oh there you go i'm sorry
um so so um with tyler and jody we
we were delighted when they took the pub
over actually
and it you know they have definitely
turned it around on the clientele are
better
and i think they'll agree that we
supported them wholeheartedly
we we send people in there we've
had groups of us going in there so you
know we
we have supported them in terms of us
having to
remove the natural hedge the foliage
that sort of
goes along the other side of their
fencing unfortunately when they took the
old fencing down
we had spent i think in total about 700
pounds getting all the
foliage removed because it just
collapsed is that right yeah that's
right it's all been replanted so we've
had
so it's cost us probably over a thousand
pounds
we accept that it would have acted as a
natural um silencer
but it just was not um we could not
maintain it that way could we
because it just all fell forward onto
the driveway i think
what which i think what is regrettable
is that tyler and jody didn't come and
talk to us
because we have in the past always
enjoyed a good relationship with them
and listening to what they've told us
now about their compromises with the
environmental agency
so on and so forth and what their plans
are
it gives me some comfort dave and i
haven't actually a chance to speak about
it obviously
but um but what i think there must be
seating for about 250
it's probably there's probably 15 plus
tables in the garden um and they have
been full upped and fully booked
in recent months and so if you do your
maths on that you've got the equivalent
of
over 100 people sitting next to our
boundary
and it's not during the week it's just
mainly
weekends fridays and saturdays that the
increase in the noise has been quite
substantial from
outside and that is why we're objecting
to
the increase a in the bar outside
and outside music because we believe
it will bring more more people in
and then what happens is the more people
three we we're realistic we know we
bought a house next door to a pub
that's you know that is what it is but
what we find
is that um it may be different when the
doormen are there but the more people
drink the more the noise
escalates and it does i mean dave dave
has
a text tyler audrey i i i've spoken
what he'll confirm that probably a month
six weeks ago i had to send a text
because the noise was
so bad on a sunday evening you know but
sometimes we can't sit in our garden and
hear ourselves talk to each other
it's um it's very different i know
because we've been in there and
you know we look when we can see our
house and you can sort of understand why
people
don't appreciate that you know it's a
heavily residential area around the pub
um i mean i say i'll go in there myself
i
i like the pub i respect what they've
done to the pub you know and everything
um but it is the noise that affects us
it may help if if the noise before it
escalates because
sometimes the language is appalling um
[Music]
you know and you you can feel it
building up throughout the afternoon
and sometimes that is in the week as
well yeah yeah
so the only reason you haven't seen me
tyler and jody is because i'm not
allowed in on a thursday because it's a
man's night
it is but um yeah so so just generally
we're already
sort of um we already get a lot of light
from there
there's a the the noise the smell of the
cooking is it the generator
because because the there's been an
increase in the outside area
obviously a lot of people more people
are eating outside
i mean it's not a horrible smell but we
do get food
smells because we're five
six meters away from the fence along our
boundary there
and um because the
kitchen has being used more and more
the extractor fan is being used more and
more obviously so
we're there's a bit of an increased
noise for us as well
yeah i think just generally it's it's
generally
the noise level over a weekend
that's our that's our only concern
and that the conditions
lifting and new barrier will bring
i know tyler said um it won't bring more
people
but we've our concern is that it does
and it will yeah okay right thank you is
is uh any other points you'd like to
make at the moment
no just whether whether they naturally
needed planning permission to build the
bar
that i can't answer that no anything no
it's anything to this committee i'm
afraid
yeah i think um we with your permission
that we can ask tyler and jody
they would know
um well we don't need planning mission
normally that's that's
nothing to do with this hearing at the
moment thank you very much for that may
i ask at this point to ask um
any members of the committee to ask
questions
um firstly councillor newport do you
have any questions for
nothing at all thank you thanks for
gooding you have any questions
so if you don't mind me asking tracy how
long have you actually lived
seven years this month fair enough fine
thank you
anything else council getting
[Music]
no thank you um i'd like just to answer
a couple of questions have you ever had
need to call the police to
any incidents at the public house no we
haven't
no but what we've tried to do is deal
with it directly with previous landlords
sorry we accept they're trying to run a
business you know we're
business people ourselves and i've done
a very good job
but yeah so in the past when it was
under different owners and
it was worse i've got to admit that but
we've always tried to deal directly with
the landlord
rather than get police involved okay um
when you moved in there it was an
operating public house i presume
it was yes it was just for clarity um
i've looked at the public are you on
looking at it from from the road looking
at the
pump are you on the right hand side on
the left-hand side we're on the
left-hand side
separated by a driveway by a driveway so
you're not adjoining
your your um detached hands
our garden is approximately six meters
away
from their fence okay
thank you that's most helpful thank you
very much
uh can i just say something um yeah
can you hear me yeah when it was the
anchor
when we first moved in there was
probably five or six tables outside that
it wasn't used that much out as an
outside eating or seating area
yeah and they they could only have they
had to install air conditioning
so that if they wanted live music it had
to be indoors with the door shut
okay thank you um right if anybody and
any other interested
parties have any questions they would
like to ask now is the time
no thank you no right thank you very
much
um
[Music]
the the the the two interesting part is
you have two minutes now each if you
wish to
sum up on your your your points that
you'd like to make
okay um so i think
obviously we do we do respect tracy and
dave's points
um however i feel
their main concern is the fact that the
pub is busy
i know dave says he thinks that he but
the outside bar is going to bring more
people
and i mean that's yet to be seen and you
know no one will really know
we don't feel it's necessary to attract
more people we just think it's going to
give them a different route to actually
get their drinks
um but it seems to me like the the
problem is the fact
of the noise and the general place being
a slightly busier pub now
and obviously this application is for an
outside building and for
music at the weekends it's not you know
that's a lot of things they bring up
like the smells in the kitchen
the noise and that that that isn't
really impacted by the
outside bar we don't feel um
so i can't see that being you know i
don't know how that's going to affect it
and change it
we've got to be busy it has to be busy
um
yes we've got more tables in the garden
um obviously
that was primarily lead because of covid
uh as we've got busier you know they are
getting taken up
i know they said it's book the garden's
booked out most weekends we don't
actually book our garden area out that's
the walk-ins only and the last couple of
weekends obviously when it's bad weather
it's it's probably 80 empty when it's
not nice weather
it's only on the occasion on the
occasion when it's a nice day that
actually the garden gets filled up
and that normally empties out by about
eight to nine o'clock in the garden
itself for people tend to move
inside or into the undercover area um
i know they say oh they said we could
have spoke to them yeah maybe we should
have
um i'll be honest with you we didn't
think it would impact them
so therefore didn't feel the need to
speak to them i mean we we
let's say dave's in most thursdays we
speak to them guys
they could have spoke to us if they had
any problems they saw it going up
um i don't know maybe we could have
spoke to them but as i say we didn't
feel that they'd have any objections or
any
interest in it really because we don't
feel it makes any difference to
the problem that they're raising which
is the general noise the bar outside we
don't feel makes any difference to that
okay and we're both i'd just like to add
us also that we are both
boys that have grown up in wakering
we've been here 40 years ourselves
my brother jody lives within a hundred
yards of the pub um
so we're quite well known in the in the
village and we want to make sure that we
keep
the pub going in the right direction
which is to keep it busy
but controlled and we want to keep the
food going and we really want to make it
an asset to the village
rather than a late night drinking place
because obviously we could keep it open
until one o'clock in the morning
we being really you know people have
grown up the village just don't want
that to be the case and we'd rather them
go
up the other end of the village if they
want a late-night drink and we'll keep
you know the nicer people in our pub
but we just really need the help to do
that really
our only concerns was about the noise
that is um
normally we wouldn't be here today i'll
say we like the guys
what they've done is excellent but
we have been suffering a lot over the
last
few months with the massive increase in
noise
and i say if you can imagine you know
you've got a hundred people within six
meters of
you all outside all trying to drink in
and all trying to do one over and
speaking louder and louder and louder
and it does get out of hand
music i think the music will attract
more customers
it's got to yeah i mean i know from when
we've been in there when anita
carmichael was playing i know it's
indoors
but about fifth now about 10 or 15 of
my friends came and they wouldn't have
normally have been there
so i do think it will attract more more
customers
okay thank you um you obviously have um
you obviously have a good relationship
with
the the the applicant so whatever
happens i hope that will continue
yeah we've got no we've got no problem
it's just
what we've started our problem is what
we've stated yeah
okay thank you um licensing obviously do
you have any comments that you'd like to
make
no thank you thank you mr owen anything
no thank you chad i think that's all
good okay any other any other comments
right thank you very much for that um
one conclusion the subcommittee will now
adjourn to consider the case and may
request the presence of the legal
advisor
to provide legal advice we will return
i've got here
we were in approximately how many
minutes i'm not sure what we're going to
do now now perhaps um
sonya can you advise please
i i think if we um if we allow about 40
minutes
chairman um and i'm assuming that the
licensing officer has got contact
details for
for for all parties so if there's any
variation on that we'll
liaise with her well thank you all for
attending it's most interesting most
helpful thank you very much and we'll
let you know as soon as we know thank
you